ce toy ou dostoïevski un essai de george
steiner georges stener est américain il
enseigne actuellement à l'université
britannique de cambridge
georges stener vous écrivez dans votre
livre et c'est même la phrase choc qui
apparaît sur la bande du livre vous
écrivez demandé à un homme s'il préfère
tolstoï dostoïevski vous connaîtrez le
secret de son coeur pourquoi faire de
tolstoï et dostoïevski ces cas limites
en quelque sorte c'est qu'un test
il est des oeuvres d'art qui nous force
en quelque sorte à choisir parce qu elle
vous prennent à la gorge pour ainsi dire
et elles disent voilà une vision du
monde de dieu de votre rôle dans le
monde
choisissez entre nous on les visions
opposées antagonistes et pour moi ce
sont là les deux géants du roman qui est
après tout la forme contemporaine par
excellence la forme qui a succédé au
poème épique au drame tragique
nous sommes dans le siècle si vous
voulez ou dans le second siècle du roman
et ce sont les deux grands maîtres de
cette forme et quoi que nous puissions
les apprécier tous deux je crois que
chaque homme en soit choisi l'un plutôt
que l'autre
c'est à dire disons 'peut-être que
simplifier les choses le rationalisme et
puis l'autre par l'irrationnel
dostoïevski en sommet pour simplifier
dit au monde entier si vous voulez le
royaume de la justice sur terre noyon de
la raison vous aboutissez par la ruine
par l'inhumain par le monde
concentrationnaire qu'il a prévus dans
les possédés et rae karamazov et tolstoï
ninon c'est ici qu'il faut bâtir le
royaume de l'homme et de dieu et si vous
et vous esquivez en pensant au ciel au
transcendant
alors vous aboutirez par l'injustice et
les deux solutions sont antagonistes et
très et demi elle ne s'arrête pas
également toutes deux et je crois
d'instinct de raison de sensibilité ne
choisissons pourquoi le plus précisément
avoir choisi deux russes parce que je
crois que dans le roman
ce sont les géants le géant qui
définissent les limites même de cette
forme
il ya eu trois très grand moment dans
notre littérature le moment grecque
les tragiques grecs le mans
en shakespearien normand restée moment
d'ailleurs très curieusement bref n'est
ce pas entre les débuts de gogol et la
fin de tolstoï 60 ans 60 fulgurante avec
des chefs-d'oeuvre presque tout les ans
tous les ans comme sous shakespeare et
10 ou 12 très grands contemporains
ce sont ces moments des moments de crise
d'habitude la proche de révolution ou de
chutes de civilisation ou la littérature
semble porter cette charge d'angoise de
révolution les grandes questions que la
philosophie pose d'une façon abstraite
lviv dans le mode littéraire et tolstoï
et dostoïevski ont montré que le roman
peut tenir tête à sophocle aïchi la
shakespeare
oui mais tout de même nous avons
tendance à croire que le roman le grand
roman est né et a vécu aussi ailleurs
qu'en russie en france par exemple le
roman français a pris la décision d'être
entièrement un grand roman séculier
c'est à dire que lorsque balzac cresson
monde génial c'est le monde
la bourgeoisie du paysan c'est ce monde
sans dieu il effleure le problème de
dieu mais dans le très mauvais livres
dans séraphine tas dans le christ en
flandre chez proust il y à leur fut un
refus de génie si vous voulez mais
d'ouvrir les portes vers le ciel ou
l'enfer imaginez mitia karamazov en
chaussettes avec dieu au plafond hurlant
avec son âme
ça ne va pas dans proust ni les
chaussettes sales par iliad en cause de
la saleté mais jamais du mauvais goût ni
dieu et pour simplifier naïvement les
chaussées de salé la présence de dieu
vont ensemble elles vont ensemble en
shakespeare
elles vont ensemble paraît grand poème
épique et aussi dans le roman russe il
est remarquable que le roman français
est produit madame bovary tolstoï répond
par anna karénine le roman français
produit le rouge le noir où la
chartreuse de parme avec leurs
politiques et leurs napoléon dans le sto
et répond par guerre et paix et d'os tf
qui par les possédés et
est ce que vous pensez du roman français
actuel eh bien il est presque
l'aboutissement de ce triomphe du style
de l'autonomie de la cadence et du
langage sur le contenu humain je vois
bientôt que le roman français va nous
présenter des oeuvres ou des chats et
chaises et des tables vont parler entre
elles et puis le dernier grand roman
français goristes de cette vague du
nouveau roman ce sera un roman à
feuilles blanches ça doit venir ça a
débuté par mallarmé qui est le maître du
roman français actuel qu'à la fin ce
sera un silence
le silence peut être très beau silence
si vous voulez sur beau papier c'est le
point de vue d'un américain vous nous
donnez là que vous êtes américains oui
mais et point de vue j'espère d'un
américain éduqué en france qui doit à la
france qu'il a lui-même de culture
littéraire
non j'espère point de vue d'un homme qui
lit et qui croient qu'il est un espèce
de très hautes frivolité le très bel
formellement très intéressante mais
frivolité unis mènent à vider le roman
de la voix humaine de la présence du
corps humain qui après tout sont la base
du langage ne sommes pas en train de
faire de la musique ne sommes pas en
train de faire du pôle clé de l'art
abstrait nous travaillons avec les mots
et les mots existent dans la voix
humaine et c'est ce que tolstoï
dostoïevski n'oublie jamais même quand
ils prennent le risque du mauvais goût
des longueurs du ridicule du grotesque
mais ils prennent ces grands risques et
c'est ce qui manque dans ces petits
livres main c'est parfait qu'on nous
offre maintenant car après tout entre un
livre très gros et un livre mince la
différence est presque d'ordre
métaphysique non seulement technique
le livre très mince c'est toujours la
princesse de clèves ça se refuse à la
vie avec intelligence art qu'est ce que
vous voulez mais il ya là un certain
revue parce que la vie n'est pas un
livre mince elle est terriblement longue
et touffue et danse et tolstoï ne
voulait même pas arrêter guerre et paix
2 et pilar huit chapitres nouveau
c'était comme le temps lui-même en
marche et dossier stick écrit ses livres
gigantesque précisément parce qu'il veut
toujours recommencée le réel
souvenons nous que les frères karamazov
c'est le premier volume d'un cycle qu'il
n'a pas pu écrire il est mort et bien je
vous remercie georges stener et je
rappelle que votre livre tolstoï et
dostoïevski après avoir paru aux états
unis en angleterre et dans quelques
autres pays paraît en france aux
éditions du seuil dans la traduction de
rose saisis
[Musique]